[Music]
and
chick-fil-a defense news oh what are
they doing i will defend chick-fil-a
until i die i [ __ ] love you why is
your mouth all full
i got potassium meat in my mouth
don't say that he sounds gross you
sounded interested for a little bit
well yeah because it's bart he always
has some tupperware container full of
something i don't want to eat
like this thing like over there yeah
right exactly oh thank you
hey what is that isn't that nestle or
whatever dude it's it's water yes that's
some of that nestle no
it's water it's nestle pure life people
don't like that
don't give it a come on cause we're
gonna come come after you for that see
just just let you know don't give him
the brand because then he's gonna
latch onto it because they steal from
other like some little town they say
something water or some [ __ ] oh people
say that stuff oh wait does that any
other
no about nestle about nestle it's
something that i have read one time and
i'm like oh i know people get angry
bad comments my way for sure submitted
by raindrop drop
chop drop keep falling out we wasn't
strong
was it rain drop you just did that
completely alone and no one had your
back
who's oldest in this room take a guess
and no and it's also who has kids
like right now current babies oh true me
brain job
a dishwasher was awarded 21.5 million
dollars
for being forced to work on sundays a
dishwasher i was thinking the machine
dishwasher me too
they have a dishwasher suit something
you know what i thought the same thing
when i first read this same dude i was
just like
we're [ __ ] over the [ __ ] edge
right now i love bragging about
absolute abject stupidity i was thinking
it was an inanimate object me too
me too it was confused you know what i
thought it was i thought it was a troll
like someone's going you want to see how
stupid you guys are this dishwasher is
about to see well i knew
i knew it was just like the egg photo
right however yeah yeah yeah yeah like
it's so stupid well i knew it was a
human
but i thought there were clothes on
sundays oh that's pretty good i've been
there so many times on sundays like oh
[ __ ] they're close
yeah they are closed then why are they
working on sundays wait what are you
talking about
it's the defense that chick-fil-a had
used which is
the religious defense yeah as to why
they close on sundays yeah
which is the same defense that this
woman used so she's saying that she is
forced to work on the day that
chick-fil-a is close
on the sabbath i don't know i have
nothing to do with the picture or a
religious
holiday or whatever yeah but how do you
work out a place if the establishment's
not even open
no no no no no you're thinking about
chick-fil-a let me tell you this you're
raising everything lady does not work at
chick-fil-a everything
wipe deleting so a hotel dishwasher
a hotel not chicken chick-fil-a is going
into hospitality i'm just kidding
stick with me so her name is marie jane
pierre and she's very fond
jean-pierre
yeah he's an idiot yeah that's true hey
he's not an idiot
i didn't recognize the pierre until i
got to it but this is like the third
time you got today
it's okay can we move on yes i do like
that lipstick
you don't have any and then do you know
how late last night i got home because i
was cooking because we were cooking a
pie
okay that's not a good defense that's
not a good deal it was worth it that pie
is really good
because he enjoyed the pie that's a
great defense yeah that's a good defense
that's good i like that the pie is from
chick-fil-a oh my god
good job that was actually good that was
good so this woman she has been working
at this hotel from 2009 oh no wait
uh for a long time right she's sick
you're like [ __ ] i [ __ ] the facts
[ __ ] the math long time no yeah because
they did put dates in here but during
those dates which was seven years from
2009 to 2014 they allowed her to not
have sunday shifts
because she had been requesting for her
not to work on sunday because she goes
to church she's a devout baptist and so
they for those seven years are like cool
you won't work on sundays
but then in 2015 they began
demanding that she start working again
and so they would
they would schedule her in on sundays
even though
she's repeatedly requested not to work
on sundays and so they would force her
to either work and then it led to the
point where
she was fired because she was absent on
those dates
so because of that she was able to win
21.5 million
that's insane yeah so she was awarded
536 000
in damages damage is how to compensation
for lost wages emotional pain and mental
anguish and
25 million in lost wages she goes to
church
no 536 000 but then it was 20 million in
punitive damages but
she's going to get way less than that
because in florida which this is where
it takes place
they have a cat oh which is 300 000.
oh my god how much 300. wait what's the
point of getting a judgment for that one
yeah exactly
that's like getting 17 life sentences
yeah they always do that [ __ ]
and we do declare bob martin is guilty
of 17 different separate life sentences
and he will be serving every single one
sentence can get shortened by on good
behavior so they want to make sure
absolutely sure that you're in there for
life yeah you just got
owned it's not really an own thing it's
more just like a
why like for example if you have a life
sentence and you're doing a good you're
being a good real good boy
you're being a good boy they're like hey
you're chill we're going to let you off
your life sentence
does that happen yeah no they shorten it
down to them you get a life sentence
they they shorten it you can shorten it
on like some
for whatever just because you don't
chuck your lunch tray at somebody
and [ __ ] so instead of getting out at 90
you get out at 85.
no it's early i don't know about live
streams i don't know either but why
would they assign so many live sentences
i think because each account she doesn't
know anything and you know you gave her
charge needs a separate sentence well
yeah i know okay so that each charge got
a life sentence
well it makes a lot of sense yeah
exactly thank you anyway
this lady she didn't get millions she
got 300 000. so the punitive damages was
only 300 000.
and she still got the 500 thousand she
got 500. she's getting like a thousand
in damages eight hundred thousand like a
million dollars
damn that's still a lot of money but how
much did the lawyer take i know right
i guess i have to think about this a
little bit off the bat i disagree with
the lady because
like you're agreeing to work at an
establishment you don't get to set the
rules and no one's forcing you to work
there you can choose to work somewhere
else that does give you it sounds like
she
she was like okay you're not forcing me
to work i'm gonna go to church on sunday
and then she got fired anyway
it seems like they didn't like that she
was taking sundays off so they wanted to
fire her so they started scheduling her
so that they could fire her
like they just needed charges like on
her list
because they have this uh so she sued
claiming that the hotel violated
the civil rights act of 1964 which bars
race religious and gender discrimination
by
employers but that's like i mean how
hard is it really for the hotel to just
not schedule her on sunday right
it looks like for the first seven years
yeah it was okay maybe there were other
reasons that they wanted to fire her
and then they just for sure used that
because they knew that she always farts
she's like farting in the back she could
be a real tutor yeah she could be true
yeah that's a really great picture she
had a renaissance fair
very colonial yeah wow dude this is the
kind of lady who's like
god will take care of me and then
everyone's like whatever and then one
day god gives her 22 million dollars
and she's like i told you i'll suck my
[ __ ] dick
like god took care of me i like i'll
suck my dick and god is in the exact
same sentence
they're they're flawed people we're all
flawed people yeah yeah yeah we're all
sinners we have punitive damages what
does that even mean
i had to search that up too and it's
just well we have a lawyer here why
don't we just have her
shut the [ __ ] up i said to you to 50
life sentences
then you're never going to get this
sentence right now nice
we're not married right now look at now
shut the [ __ ] up oh [ __ ] hey neither are
we it's okay i'm on the market
i already steve where's your ring i
don't have it i forgot it who cares
i have mine we're fighting she doesn't
need
not married today it's not a good day
today not a good day
okay so i googled a punitive damages
where it says damage is exceeding simple
compensation and rewarded to punish the
defendant oh
just to punish them punishment damage
you're paying
i like it it sounds like peanut penis
yeah nice
yeah i love that i like that you gave up
on it as you were saying that's what i
was like
you heard how dumb it sounded you're
like [ __ ] it you're like why did i say
anything at all
yeah i was like as though the words were
coming out i was like oh no
that's why you didn't have very many
friends when you're in school huh oh my
god
two persons you shouldn't even give it
to me the whole idea
of like hitting back it's like i go he
and he goes
damn wait did he have any friends like
oh yeah yeah
yeah he's very popular he tells me about
it all the time oh but tell him about
the award that he wants oh he won the
award for master of sassiness what is
that
oh i know know i was just they
misspelled on the trophy i got master of
scenes
but it's fine that's how she that's how
she does that's how she gets me she's
never won a trophy in her life right now
so he would brag about how
i've never won a trophy and he's run a
trophy i have so many trophies
i don't even know what to do with all my
trophies well your wife is a trophy
that's for sure so you keep winning
trophies [ __ ] i know that's what i'm
saying no that was not a test it's
killing it
and then when you know what he does he
goes i'm killing it so hard i'm gonna
pull my wife down even further you
didn't have friends growing up that's
crazy
you want to make her cry again i'll do
it i don't want to watch this again
nobody knows what you're talking about
go to their podcast
and listen to every single episode until
you find the one that i'm talking about
no we didn't hear it
that's good that's good uh what we
didn't hear it of course it aired
oh you're right we did we did we know we
cut it out we cut you out
no i was backing you up you stupid
hooker
listen to the podcast you know what
happened and it was just plugging your
podcast
i i cut all of this out i picked up on
it words just keep coming out and i'm
like
wait you know and then when you gave
steve the birthday i mean not birthday
christmas present she was like
is it views in there you were just
gifting her that i said it was stupid
and then she says is it me that's in the
present oh
yeah you called me stupid you [ __ ]
[ __ ] you got the baby shark socks look
at my head you didn't have any friends
now i see why you don't have any friends
you shouldn't bring my friends i don't
even want friends they're so mean
she said because i put a baby shark song
in her head
it's okay you guys can move on we're
gonna we're gonna keep going but you
guys
you guys can move on they're like next
video yep
baby no no
don't do it it's not cool did this to me
don't turn it on me you're the [ __ ]
of this episode
please like me specify this episode next
episode i'll be the [ __ ]
[Music]
you